we do believe at UNESCO and I personally
am very much committed to girls
education and women's empowerment I do
believe in the first place that
education is one of the best investments
in order to achieve sustainability in
any development but particularly girls
because in many parts of the world girls
are a synonym with poverty in the rural
areas girls are the marginalized the
communities in the communities there are
still a lot of stereotypes and because
poverty has sometimes a woman's face
investing in girls education and we have
a lot of data a lot of research in this
particular area improves communities
standard of living eradicate so poverty
has a particularly important and
positive impact on health
we know that educated women that have
passed through primary education are
carrying better for their children for
their families and also for the
environment investing in girls education
is also one of the main I would say
objectives of education for all which is
the second millennium development goal
and without achieving gender parity in
primary education and also moving to the
secondary education we can we cannot
achieve also what nowadays is considered
one of the objectives of the
international community to eradicate
extreme poverty by the year 2030
and why we speak now about girls
education because still inequalities are
there only 58% of the countries have
achieved gender parity in primary
education and only 38% gender parity in
secondary education when girls are in
school and our appeal it's let's keep
girls
in school they marry late they get
pregnant late there when they're in
school they're much more protected in
other if not to get contaminated with
some diseases and they're less also
protected I would say protective against
violence keeping girls in school after
primary education is the best investment
in our development I believe that in
terms of education it's it's a value in
any society education is I would say
also a cultural value in many societies
although we know that stereotypes
sometimes put girls and marginalized
also populations in in disadvantage we
we believe that if we unite around
education religious leaders traditional
leaders in many communities of course
having a very focused public policies
and in government commitments and make
an education a true value for families
we will then achieve also sustainability
in all our development efforts we don't
believe that there is a drastic position
between cultural values and educational
values i we do believe that if we put it
right if we unite around this idea of
education being one of the best
investment for having healthy families
for having healthy communities for
having also I would say a better living
education is a better living also for
these communities and these families
then we can convince also everybody and
unite around achieving this important
goal of access to quality education and
lifelong learning for all
I think the strategy to get children
into school or on one side and we have
already done it it is to put education
on the global political agenda in the
United Nations and we have now the
education first initiative of the
secretary-general mr. ban ki-moon who is
the first one to put education with such
a commitment and such a responsibility
on the agenda of the United Nations we
have to have in the post-2015 agenda on
sustained sustainable development we
have to have a one very strong goal
sustainable goal which is achieving and
free access to quality education and
lifelong learning for all and then of
course we have to have a very strong
commitment of governments of the civil
society of the private sector also to
reach the marginalized we cannot
continue business as usual because if we
want to eradicate extreme poverty if we
have to move with the agenda of
sustainability if we want to tackle the
problems of climate change if we want
also to in some cases also shift the
paradigm of development to Ed I would
say a developmental aspect to all the
issues about economic development to
have the three legs of sustainable
development economic the social and the
environmental we cannot do that
separately from education so I believe
if we integrate education in these
strategies of sustainable development
then we will be successful
I think the teaching and learning is
shifting nowadays we speak not just
about education we're speaking about
learning and this shift in our thinking
about learning is very much linked also
to the new technologies it's very much
linked to a new a very different
environment that we are living through
where there is a broad access to
information through the new
communication technologies which gives a
lot of opportunity also for high quality
of teaching and learning so on one side
we have to bridge the digital divide
this is the question about access to
online information it is about the
broadband we are working there through
the broadband Commission in order to
promote broadband and connectivity in
those parts of the world where still we
see this digital divide which is
preventing many communities and in
people and young people and others from
this access on the other side we have to
admit that the the new technology the
technologists overall it's not a name in
itself it is a means to achieving this
learning and it is about also the
content it is about what kind of global
citizens we we want to to create
nowadays through the process of
schooling and learning and this is about
values so this is about understanding
about the others this is about I would
say what kind of of young people come
out of schools we don't want to have out
of schools some kind of robots we want
to have young people who have skills but
also who are culturally literate young
people who understand about the others
young people who who know what is a
stake nowadays who are with values about
human rights about human dignity about
communities and about the others so we
Paulette and within the global education
first initiative we have put the third
main objective of this initiative global
citizenship education for global
citizenship and I think this is a time
to speak about it it is about education
for sustainable development we are
having a major global forum later this
year in November in Nagoya in Japan
which is forum about education for
sustainable development so the stakes
are very high
nowadays with all the challenges that we
have and we want that the all these I
would say global learning and education
is about global citizenship and that
young people know what is a stake